uh thanks for coming back to the next
session
uh so our next speaker is uh you know
chi jin we're excited to have him be
here uh and he's gonna be telling us
about uh you know the recent work he's
been doing on sort of decentralized
algorithms for uh you know multi-agent
rl in markup games so i'll
i'll let him take it away okay
um thanks for the introduction uh my
name is xi jin from princeton university
and today i'm going to talk about our
work on the vlearning
whereas essential a simple efficient
decentralized algorithm for
multi-general reinforcement learning
although the title is like a
multi-generation learning but i also
want to emphasize this algorithm b
learning is actually a single agent
algorithm
itself okay and uh
the reason we call it relearning is uh
because it's as simple as secure
learning the well-known algorithm you
you probably know but uh
instead we say it's multigen because we
can basically prove for q learning a lot
of property is not very good for multi
agents but for this vlearning stat
although it's as simple as q learning
but it actually has a lot of great
desire
property for this multi-gene
reinforcement learning
it is decentralized efficient and we
will also see later it actually breaks
the curse of multiagents
okay
so hope this uh catch your attention i
will first do a brief overview of the
result
okay first i want to also thanks to the
my wonderful collaborators and this work
will not be possible without them
versus you bai who's probably an
audience who is from salesforce and also
my students at princeton university both
ching halio and
they are wonderful
wonderful collaborators and also my
collaborators attention you
he's also a phd student from mit
okay first we'll get to attention of
what is the problems we'll be focusing
on in this uh talk so the problems will
be like those problems like starcraft
like highland six or like poker or like
go basically we have two common
characteristics about those problems one
is uh it involves a sequential decision
making so it is a reinforced learning
problem so we not only need to decide
one action but we need to based on the
feedback of the opponent or the
environment we need to make a bunch of
decisions in us in like in a series
the second thing is different from a
single reinforcement problems now we're
not playing against some fixed
environments we're actually playing
against some opponents which possibly
they can change their policies during
the during their playing also the
opponent can even be adapted that is i'm
playing some policy my opponent can
realize oh i'm playing some social
policy and they can adapt it and to
exploit my behavior
okay so this makes it a lot challenging
so this also defines what is a
multi-gene reinforcement problems we're
interested basically the multi-gene
reinforcement learning problems can be
considered as a combination of the two
categories one is a classical game
theory where we're dealing with a play
players playing against each other and
we kind of want to find a nash
equilibrium or some other equilibrium
the other thing is like the
reinforcement learning we need to deal
with a sequence of decisions and we need
to make a
like like the good decisions a good
actions in the next step based on the
feedbacks in the previous steps so this
gives a multi-year reinforcement
learning
and specifically like in informalism we
will consider model of markov game where
we're kind of like following the
reinforcement learning we know
reinforcement learning we usually study
the model called my composition process
so markup game can be considered as a
standard extension notation extension of
mark of division process we will specify
what is exactly like the definition of
minecraft games later but for now we
just think this is a multi-agent
extension of markov division process and
in the literature it also known as
stochastic games which was i proposed
like
50 years ago
so a lot of the things in the multitude
reinforcement learning or markov games
can be adapted from like our results
from our conversational process that is
a single asian version we kind of like
we combine with the games and deal with
and we extend it to the multi-generation
version of
the games markup games however there are
several challenges which is unique in
this multi-gene reinforcement learning
where single-engine reinforcement has
absolutely no idea how to address of
them one such unique challenge is
so-called cursive multiagents
if we look at the size of games where if
if we have like
n players
what we need to like specify what is the
utility for the single player i that the
utility is gonna depends on all the
actions of other opponents so this size
or the complexity of game is actually
gonna grows with exponentially with
number of agents so this is what we call
cursive multiagents
and we will see later if we naively
adapt a single engine reinforcement
learning algorithm here we're actually
going to pay some complexity that is
exponential in this number of agents
which is quite undesirable like if we
want to
design some multi-system for like 10
drones or 20 zones that's going to be
disaster like we don't have enough
samples to train good policy for those
kind of
systems
the other thing is about unique
challenges about the centralized
algorithm versus decentralized algorithm
in a single region learning scenario
there's no such this
like difference with every algorithm is
like either centralized or decentralized
it's the same thing so the decentralized
algorithm in the modular system means
we hope we can have some algorithm so
that our players all ages just simply
run the same algorithm independently
okay they just need to run a single
same single origin algorithm
independently like as if they don't
really know whether there are some other
players or not and the benefit of doing
such things is it's kind of economic
first agnostic against other players
actions
and also it's uh
it can be implemented much easier
because you just need to implement a
single user learning algorithm and
finally we can like reduce a lot of
communication because it's uh
each algorithm just each agent just run
independently so it doesn't really
require any communication
so the main question in this talk is can
we actually design a decentralized
multi-reinforcement algorithm that
breaks the curse of multi-agents so the
two challenges we talked about here is
one decentralized algorithm
and the second one is the curse of
multi-agents
it sounds like a very fancy goal we want
to achieve but since i present the
question here of course the answer of
this talk is yes we provided an
algorithm that are able to achieve both
of them
okay so i will just quickly brief
overview about what is our results
the result is we we need to get these
results based on a newly designed
algorithm such called vlearn okay as i
mentioned in the first slide vlearning
is actually a single agent reinforcement
algorithm so you can learn the single
engine markov vision process
and it was proposed
in our early work with
you i and me and attention in 2020.
so a couple of uh characterization why
this algorithm is able to solve both
challenges first about decentralized
we've proved that in multitude
reinforcement learning all we need to do
is we just run this v-learning algorithm
which is a single engine and learning
algorithm independently for all players
okay we don't need to any like
centralized scheme or
like collaboration or like any
connections or we just random
independently so this perfectly achieve
the decentralization
the second one is about break the curse
of multi agents
we actually can prove as well we were
handling all the perspective of learning
which including planning estimation and
exploration will explain later what is
terminology means
and we were handling all the perspective
of learning in those number of samples
okay this is a max i ai where ai is
number of action of each player
so what are we gonna cost is only the
maximum number of actions for each
player instead of the product of number
of actions for each player which is
typically the size of the game or like
the game matrix or or like the q values
if we later we will specify later
so we know this is like the curse of
dimension uh custom multi agents which
kind of grow exponentially with number
of players but this one does not grow
with number of players if all the
players have the same number of actions
so they're speaking occurs of
multi-agents
so i want to also emphasize the meaning
of this work and i will say vlearning is
the first but also remains the only
class of algorithm even until today that
is can probably address both challenges
in markov games
so you could run two learning algorithms
independently for all players so can you
can you clarify what you can run it but
you will not be able to so we need to
prove the results so we need to prove
we'll actually
convert to nash equilibrium so yeah
foreign equilibrium and q learning we
cannot prove something
that's a very good question
yeah i think the approval is important
we will address those charges
okay um that's basically the overview
so without further ado we will
any questions so far
no questions i will just directly go to
the format formulations and objectives
like what exactly we're talking about
learning
so we say we will study the multitude
reinforcement problems under formalism
of for markov games okay this markup
games is a
has a several components which is a set
of
a similar tool markov position process
which we have a set of states assets uh
and uh for simplicity uh we kind of we
deal with we kind of revealed our work
as a first step in dealing with markup
games so we started a simpler setting
which is a tabular setting we have a
finite number of states and find a
number of actions
so different from our conditional
process
here we not only have a a single set of
actions for player we will have multiple
set of actions so ai donates the set of
actions for the agents alpha ice player
and the two component two key component
of markup games one is transition
transition is about your transform
probability starting from the current
states to the next states and the
important thing is it's conditioned on
the joint action okay we will see this
action with this uh
like bold folder means the joint action
of all the players
a1 to am that we need to put out the
player other player will play the action
simultaneously and then we will
transition the system from the current
state to the next stage
and we will also have a reward for each
player so each player will have
different rewards so this is like a
general formalism about general some
markup games where we use i to denote
the reward received by the ice agent h
means the
the reward we're going to receive at the
step h okay and depends on the current
states as well as the joint actions so
finally we consider episodic setting
that means we just consider the game
where we always stop in age steps uh h
is the horizon or the length of games
yes
on the current states
also also on the stage here also on the
states
on the current steps yeah so basically
for different steps we can have
different transitions from s1 to s2 we
can have some transition that is
different from s2 to s3
it's not stationary yeah it's not
non-stationary it's kind of like a
little bit more general than stationary
setting but we can definitely also
handle the stationary settings
uh we will talk about that objectively
later yeah
that's a good point yeah sorry
i think for shapley's work zero sum is
your worth zero oh no this is not zero
sum i think sharply's work can also be
extended to like uh
general sounds
and did you just say the
game is finite
finite horizon also finance states
finite actions
okay so everything is finite okay
okay and we'll just quickly introduce
the what do we mean by policy and value
both of the concepts that follows very
similar to the single vision
reinforcement learning setting the
policy for the ice player is we it's
just a map that from the current states
and which steps we're taking this policy
to the distribution of our actions okay
so here the randomized policy is very
important because if we find an
equilibrium most of them are like a
randomized policy so it's a map to a
distribution of reactions instead of
just a single actions
and also we can define the values where
we have two divide two different values
one is the v value the other one is q
values similarly
we have values for each valuable for
each player i and it depends on some
policy path so this value will define as
a cumulative reward that is all the
summation of the rewards in the future
if all the players are playing again
according to this joint policy path okay
so this policy pi actually decodes all
the policies of all the players and
starting from the current state s or
state action essay depends on like
whether it's q value or v value at a
step edge
okay just uh same thing as single engine
reinforcement the only difference is
like now we have index i denotes the
utility for ice clear and the policy is
gonna depends on all the players
so you can condition on what from what's
h in square bracket
this is like the this is a okay so here
i'm just writing very simple this is
just a one two three four like index of
of steps but you're right you can also
have a policy the general policy not
this is like mark or policy but general
policy kind of depends on everything
happening in the past like not only the
current states but also everything
happened
right you're not debugging from that for
the moment is that for that uh
right i think here for simplicity i just
defined the markov strategy which only
depends on current states but later we
will also deal with the policy that
depends on entire history you're right
that's the basic definition of
for the games strategy for the games
okay and i'll just also quickly clarify
what is setting we're talking about in
order to learn the equilibrium or like a
good policy for this game so there are
several different strategies one is like
we just learned from the experts and
this one is is not what we're using but
there are several drawbacks of such
approach like it's expensive it's also
slow like expensive we need a lot of
money to hire the experts and it's slow
because the computer can run a lot
faster than humans and also it highly
depends on the level of experts like if
expert is world champion probably it's
okay but if expert is like a
some mediocre player then then probably
the whatever the policy we learned may
not be that good
so what we will do instead is we
consider setting up cell plates so we
just completely eliminate the role of
human in this process we just learn by
ourselves so we will control all the
players and we just learn the best
policy by ourselves
so this is called like self-play setting
is our focus
so to be clear like our setting is like
we just learn learning from interactions
that means uh all we have is just have a
game let's suppose a real scenario we
just
bought a game okay this is all we have
essentially and we are allowed to
control all the players like for
starcraft i can bought two copies of
games so i can open up two computers i
can control two players like they just
let them just play against each other
but what we can do is we can only play
games as normal player do like we cannot
crack the code we cannot see what is
happening behind c we have to play as a
normal player do that is play the game
from the start to the end okay that's it
we're not allowed to cheat and we can
play the game multiple times this is
setting
and our objective is after we're
controlling all agents and play the game
for multiple steps multiple times we we
require to find the optimal strategy
we'll define what is the optimal
strategy we mean here and we hope we can
play the become the best player like for
starcraft we want to be the world
champion or something like that
okay
uh
yes so i think uh so we are allowed to
control all agents so there is a
difference between centralized algorithm
versus decentralized algorithms so in
theory we allow centralized algorithms
which have centralized controller just
to control other agents and planning for
all of them
and our algorithm design vlearning is
like a decentralized algorithm that is
although we allow to control all agents
like together but we just let them run
independent algorithms so
yeah
okay i just want to clarify like this
learning from interaction setting has
like three major components about
learning the first one is planning that
we need to compute the optimal policy
based on the known model of values okay
uh this is like a very basic part that
that that basically assume we kind of
know the entire games however in reality
we don't really know what is the rule of
game we have to learn these games from
playing that is we need to estimate the
model like transition and reward and we
also need to estimate the value based on
the collected data samples like we need
to do some fitting to estimate the model
and finally this also assumes we have
some collected data samples and i think
very important thing uh that distinguish
this work from a lot of other works is
that we also address the exploration
that is we don't assume that we
magically have some like a very good
data samples that is uh covering a lot
of uh
like all perspective of the games
instead we were just strategically
trying to design algorithms so that we
can collect informed data samples to
finish the estimation step and then
finally finish the
planning steps so we'll deal with all
three components of learning
okay
so this is about our setting like how we
want to find the
optimal strategy and the other thing is
so what is the optimal strategy we're
trying to find okay
so i want to emphasize although we're
we're saying like we just want to find
the best player like in the world but
actually the solution concept of the
game is much more complicated than like
single player setting where we have like
linear relation we say one one policy is
just better than the other policy in
terms of value here for example we can
consider the game like rock paper
scissors the strategies may not have
linear relation like it has some cyclic
relation for example i consider the
strategy a as a rock set of strategy b
as like a
um scissors strategy as a paper so we
will see like strategy a b strategy b
strategy b strategy c and but on the
other hand certain c also be strategy a
so have a cyclic structure so if we just
directly say like who is the best or
like who's gonna beat everyone like with
some large margin this is not possible
and furthermore this is about purely
about competition so we cannot just
define some linear relation and the
second thing is about general sum games
we might even prefer some collaborative
or correlated strategy and we will say
later that is in general some where
we're not necessarily just competition
we might have some collaborations so we
might face some scenario that is a
win-win to both players or to for
multiple players and we want to develop
some correlated policies
so this goes back to the equilibrium or
the solution context we're trying to
find
so the first thing is about nash
equilibrium nash equilibrium is the
product policy that is
a product policy means the policy is
independent of each player that is the
the randomness i'm gonna play for my
policy is going to independently
from the randomness the other player
plays
and so this nash equipment defines the
strategy so that no player can gain by
deviating from her own policy that is i
will not play taiwan i'll play some
other policies while fixing other
players policy while the other player
just playing according to those policies
like in the rock paper scissors case we
will we'll prove actually nash
equilibrium is just playing all actions
with one third probability
and in the two-player zero sum games the
nash equilibrium have further a more
strong meaning to this kind of scenario
that is it's also an optional policy
when always facing the best response
that is i always assume my opponent
knows me perfectly so that he can place
my best response then nash equilibrium
is the best in the minimax sense
that is uh if i always play rock my
opponent can play paper so that it can
like exploit my weakness then the one
third one third one third strategy that
is no matter my opponent how my opponent
exploiting i can always draw withdrawal
with my opponent so this is like the
mini max best policy in this two-player
zero-sum game scenario
in the multi
in a general some scenario we're seeing
there we might face some scenario where
we actually
will have the win-win situation so that
we might prefer some collaborative
strategy we will also consider a very
simple example that is a modified
version of rock paper scissors that is
uh will if we if two players play
different actions we will just
like judge according to the standard
rule of rock paper scissor
but in case of the draw that is the both
player play the same actions let's
assume we gave both player reward one
okay so instead of just draw we will
give both player reward one
so in this scenario we can see both
players will prefer to play the same
actions actually over the like they
compete with each other so in this
scenario a correlative strategy that is
so we're going to play uniformly over
either two player play rocks together or
two player play paper together or two
player play caesar together
we know this is no longer independent
policy that we cannot just implement
this policy like by both players play
independently we have to have a
centralized player that tells both
agents like what is the current policy
you want to play
okay
so this defines a so-called first
correlated equilibrium and instead of
nash equilibrium which is a product
policy here is according to policies
where again no player can gain anything
if other players are fixed
and the only subtlety here is so if i
deviate from my coordinated policy
whether i can observe like what other
player because we know like when we
implement this coordinate strategy we
need to have a centralized player that
instructs all the player like what is
the current actions you need to play so
there are subtle differences whether we
can observe
what is action i gonna play in the
current iteration or i cannot observe it
so if i can observe it it's the quality
equilibrium if i cannot observe it it's
a course-coordinated equilibrium so
those are two notions of equilibrium we
kind of we consider for the general
subjects
i just want to quickly summarize all the
relation between them so the
relationship like nash is actually the
smallest set so we can say nash is a
coordinated equilibrium and a quarterly
equilibrium is a cross-coordinated
equilibrium and we kind of like uh
motivated this correlated strategy by
the in a general summit setting like we
want to have a win-win we would like to
have some
collaborative scenarios so we might
prefer this coordinated strategies
and also
comments like which also mentioned by a
lot that is in a general some games that
is a beyond two-player zero-sum games as
long as it's more than two-player or
it's not zero-sum games we can actually
prove computing nash equilibrium is ppa
d-hard which is uh we don't really know
there's a we have no polynomial time
algorithm for computing it
however on the other hand the the like a
general notion c and cc we can always
compute it in a polynomial times by
linear programming no matter it's like a
zero sum or general sum
so our objective in this talk because
this computational constraints we will
care about the nash equilibrium only in
the two-player zero-sum game scenario
and in a general scenario we will up to
this quality equilibrium and a
cross-correlated equilibrium for more
than two players
okay so after talking about setting we
will talk about the algorithm side and
ideas how we're going to find this
equilibrium
so the first thing
we will consider the first idea we'll
consider how to find saturated
equilibrium is we want to adapt the
single engine reinforcement learning
algorithm as we mentioned earlier so
basically we have three concept
components of learning so for learning
in a single scenario we just use the
bellman optimic equation here we can
also do something similar just replace
the max by the mini max or by some like
general equilibrium in this scenario
and the most important thing is we will
estimate the transition of the markov
games or the q value of markov games
okay the either like similar like in a
single engine algorithm this is like
value iteration or q learning so we can
also have the multi-conversion like
match value tuition nash q learning or
some general version of equilibrium q
learning in our previous paper we can do
that
and then finally for exploration we just
use the standard upper confidence bounds
for exploration in reinforcement
learning
so this is the basic results we can
prove uh when adapting this single issue
reinforcement scenario to this uh markov
games
we can say this value tuition that is uh
based on estimating transition combined
with upper confidence bound this
algorithm can actually learn an epsilon
version of nash equilibrium c and cc the
only thing is like this nash equilibrium
is not computationally efficient in this
scenario but we can learn it
statistically efficiently
in this amount of episodes of play
that is as long as we play this amount
of games we can find this
amount of sample complexity can be
understand in terms of dependence on
this h which is horizon as its number of
states
and ai is number of action so here we
see this is like a curse of multi-agents
so we would pay something exponential in
the number of players and finally one
over epsilon square epsilon is like the
sub-optimality of the
approximation of what is a your final
equilibrium you're trying to find
so the major bottleneck of such approach
where we want to adapting single engine
reinforcement here is
and all the single engine reinforcement
so far relies on estimation of some
transition or the q value where we know
both transition and q value will depend
on the joint action which skills as
some product of ai which is like a big
bottleneck we cannot circumvent if we
cannot use this kind of approach if we
want to
break this curse of multiagents
so we want to just want to remind you
like we briefly mentioned earlier like
we we have two unique challenges in this
scenario one is the cursed multigens we
want to have some complexity that is
skilled with the max ai instead of a
product data so we want to have
something polynomial in the number of
players and the second thing is we want
to have decentralized algorithm this
algorithm like the algorithm represented
in the earlier slides depends on
maintaining the joint transition and
join the q value so this thing actually
requires a centralized agent that is
able to calculate this q value for all
the players and then playing um
according to that kind of thing so it's
a centralized algorithm so we want to
address both challenges
okay so in order to deal with this uh
complicated goals to achieve like both
challenges in the markov game scenario
we would like to first ask ourselves how
do we address both challenges in a
simpler setting of normal form games
normal form games is a game where we
study a lot in this classical game
theory
basically we can consider normal focus
as a special case of markup games but
without any transition or states
so basically we just say the utility of
all the player i can be represented by a
tensor that is a function depends on
eyes clear and only depends on all the
actions of each player
so in this kind of scenario like we can
see if a two player zero sum games we
can basically just uh
represent the utility as a matrix of uh
of two players
so the answer for this scenario is
actually very simple for normal form
games we can just run no regret
algorithms independently for all the
players
where the neurographic algorithm is was
designed for adversarial bandits
so we'll just want to clarify what is do
we mean by adversarial bandits also to
fill you in if you don't have any
background on this adversarial bandits
and the reserve band is basically is a
problem so we have eight different arms
and we want to pour the best arms across
and like to minimize the regret we will
define
later so the interaction protocol is
something like this at each round t the
agent will first pick up policy that is
like a probability over all the actions
and that is what a property i'm going to
put arm a what is the property here i'm
going to put on b
and the adversary will picks an out of
adversarial loss okay this loss can
actually adapt to what i played earlier
can also be a difficult account would be
whatever they want so this is a power of
this adversarial bandits because this
loss has a lot of power
and then the agent just plain an action
that samples from the policies i did i
picked earlier and then the agent will
receive a loss that is the adversarial
loss but only on this component only on
the actions i placed i do not receive uh
feedback on a lot of the other actions i
have not played so this is a adversarial
bandit scenario with ben bennett
feedback
a very simple algorithm for this that's
our bandage no regret algorithm for this
assume as if abandoned is a call to
follow the right leader
so basically we will estimate the entire
loss based on the importance weighting
because we only observe the bandit loss
that we only observe the loss for for
the action i played at round t so how
are you gonna estimate the entire loss
i'm going to based on the importance
weights that is i'm going to
have the loss on the on action i put and
with indicator whether this action is
the action i put and related by the
probability i'm gonna pull that action
and with this importance weighted loss
we can just do the updates based on the
exponential weights or update policy so
the probability i gonna play action a in
the round t is gonna um proportional to
the exponential of minus some either t
learning rate and a summation of all the
other previous loss i have that is if i
have a lot of previous loss as i made a
loss then i will have a lower
probability to play that action if i
have a very little loss for this action
then i will have a lot of probability to
play this
arm
so the important thing about this regret
and this algorithm is like we have this
regret guarantee which says uh this is
like the entire reward i gonna receive
in expectation the mu t is a policy i
played uh at around here and the lt is
the loss at around t
so if we compete against the best policy
in hinge side that is if i l1 to lt
already fixed and i choose the best
policy if i given the l1 for lt
and this l1 to lt also can be out of
zero and we're gonna prove this
regret will not scale with linear with
with like the horizon t but it will
scale with sublinearity with t so in
particular we can prove it up to some
logarithmic factor it's just square root
of a t a is the number of arms we have
for each player and a t is the horizon
the very nice thing about the null
regret algorithm is uh we can
immediately transform this neural
algorithm to equilibrium learning that
is in a two-player scenario two player
zero some scenario for example we can
measure the optimality with this duality
gap if you're familiar with online
learning i guess this will be very
familiar to you so basically the duality
gap is so we measure the
like against the best response what is
the performance of the average average
policy of the opponents versus the
average policy of myself
and this difference is a duality gap
measures uh how far away the average
policy of new tea and average policy of
multi to the nash equilibrium
so what we can do in this scenario is we
can plug in a term that is summation of
mu t q nu t and also subtract this and
plot plus this q mu t nu t and so this
this will be equal but then we can
decompose this duality gap into a regret
of the two player so this is regret of
the first player and regret of second
player
best yes best policy in a like full
tabular mdp
perspective do you get that efficiently
no you cannot talk about relationships
yeah i mean again
but this is probably for
normal phone beams yeah in microphones
you kind of
like
so the very good thing is so now you can
become also joining gaps into two part
of the rack
and then the power of no red learning is
we don't care about what is this loss
this loss can be out of zero so of
course cumulative is a is a is one of
the possible loss so we can just apply
directly apply the nowhere results and
which tells me my duality gap will only
grows with this thing like square root
of h a 1 plus a 2 times t
and if we average over the number of
iterations this will give me 1 over
square root t convergence
so that is in summary we can say this
if we play the uniform policies of mu t
and uniform policy of new t and both
players play for the wireless leader or
like no regret any no regret algorithm
will be able to find nash equilibrium in
two player zero sum games in roughly
this number of
samples that is a1 plus a2 or you can
also just say this max ay 2 because in
the 2 player like max and plus is like
the same thing
and i will also not to
be very specific but basically with the
same tricks you can actually prove in
general some games by running no regret
algorithm independently for all players
what you can do is
you can like coupling the
the policies they play at each round so
milwaukee mil2t to mil empty and then i
uniformly sample t from this uh this
like entire entire iterations so this
one will create some correlation among
those policies although at each round
each player play independent policies
but when you uniform sample from like
what runs you're gonna sample it so it
becomes correlated policy so you can
prove this policy will eventually
converge to course correlated
equilibrium and the number of samples
you need is only the maximization of i
and ai so let's achieve our
goal of like breaking the curse of
multi-agents
so this part is basically says to solve
both challenges in the like normal form
games simple setting we just ran over
algorithm and everything becomes very
easy
the very question like as a lab asked is
whether i can just directly run no
regret learning algorithms for markov
game in particular what do we mean by no
regret learning algorithm is like uh
like we just place aggression on
policies pi t and if i kind of compare
with the best market policy or best
policy or best even best market policies
and in a hinge side
can i achieve the regret that is a
polynomial in everything else and the
sublinearity
yes
additionally is it
it depends on the template right not
only
the tensor of all possible actions or
whatever like cancer yeah what's the
computational complexity of this
of this procedure
no it doesn't so so basically everyone
just ran for the regular leader so the
conditions just follow right
over their own actions on their own
matches
so it doesn't really care okay so so the
game probably will make sure what is the
loss and
sentence and your loss as long as you
have that and then you really don't need
to do that
so which pair is
the policy here is just uh each
situation has their there's a
distribution over their own actions
and we say we do the correlation here by
just a uniform example from t
so you should notice
so the representation is actually also
very
similar
okay
yeah so can we write there's no red
learning algorithm for r of g we want to
achieve the sub linear in g
so unfortunately the sad news is this is
informatively impossible
so we have a theorem which says there
exists two player zero sum games in our
very recent work we show this exists
two-player zero-sum games where the
regret if we want to compete against the
best fixed market policy okay we don't
even compete with some general policy we
just compete with markup policy in
hindsight
the regret is at least minimum of t
number of rounds we play it and also two
to the h
that is we're gonna suffer a regret that
is uh exponential in the horizon
so this thing only appears in the markov
games where we have a this like
sequential structure so we have a h
steps in normal form games this is just
one so this is obviously good
so the key observation here why such
kind of thing information is important
theoretically impossible is because in
markov games my opponents can not only
temper the reward but also can kind of
screw up the transition my opponent can
actually change the transition
so
we can actually prove other player can
encode some very long long-term
correlations to make these games very
complicated if we if we just build these
games interpersonal in like in the
perspective of just one player
so we can actually say mark of games can
simulate a poem dp a generic play ndp if
other players are allowed to play any
history dependent policy okay not not
only micro policy
so if we see this is cheating like we
don't allow other player to history to
play the history depend policy we only
allow other players to play micro policy
then we can also say they can simulate a
latent mdp essentially we have a
multiple mdp but
we're going to sample one at the very
beginning with some um
with some unknown probability and we
don't know which identity of our mdp and
we can we can actually simulate that
with several markup policies
here's one okay so here
my issue is um so is this you say
samples here and you talk simple
complexity like when anything goes um
[Music]
what is
okay
so we can actually show because both of
them are like a case of poor ndp so like
it has a partial observability it's very
difficult to learn those kind of things
it's like long-term horizon we can
easily prove there there's some known
existing like a statistical harness for
a point if you're late in mdp which
basically says you need to place this
exponential in terms of horizon to learn
this in general
so now we know for markup games no
regret learning is not possible so what
we should do we should do no regret
learning stats also so we should we
should have some algorithm which would
by passing the note no regret learning
so we note a very subtlety here um very
important subtlety here is like a
so far what we say is once we have a
node we're learning algorithm we're able
to give you a um like an algorithm that
able to find the equilibrium very fast
however our final goal is we just want
to find equilibrium
so it doesn't necessarily mean so we
have to have a no regret learning
algorithm
so what we're going to do for macro game
is so we will focus on this here finding
equilibrium but we will not have a no
regret learning algorithm because this
is not possible
okay so this means that despite knowing
where learning is possible for marco
microgame we can use this idea so we
will use the principle here to design an
efficient algorithm that is only able to
find equilibrium
this is like how we design this
v-learning algorithms
so just quickly go over the algorithms
it's actually quite simple
so the first step is very like we we
have a k iterations and we have eight
steps and we just take some actions
according to my policy observer rewards
and next stage and we update the
counting where we we kind of maintain
accounting for states so all the staff
are very standard so the only key steps
are those two steps
which noted as a blue and
red
so this blue steps basically says we're
going to have an incremental update on
the v value okay so the v value is going
to be updated as a one minus r for
fraction of my previous v value and plus
alpha fraction of the new updates i
observed new samples are observed that
is a current reward i observed and the
value of the next states and plus some
beta which we will have some bonus in
estimating the value which we just use
half in bonus is the standard thing in
the upper confidence balance
so the important thing is here we have
incremental updates on the b value
instead of q value we note like the q
value have some
some bottlenecks which will depend on
all actions the size of curvature
depends on all actions however the v
values only have a size of s so this is
a very important thing how we get rid of
this exponential dependence on the
number of actions
and the second thing is uh the benefit
of q value likelihood in a single engine
setting why we use q value instead of v
value is because q value can give you a
policy we just do r max over actions we
have a policy for q learning
however here we just have a v values we
have no policies so this is why we will
use no regret learning algorithms
to compute the policy for us so what
we're going to do is we're going to run
the no
learning algorithm for each state sh
okay and we're gonna feed the number of
feed the actions i i put and feed the
fictitious reward or the loss i received
that is rh plus vh plus sh plus one
so this one will make this a regret like
this norway learning algorithm and
pretends is is a playing adversarial
like a bandit problem
for each states differently so we just
use this algorithm to give me a policy
we can use a like exponential with
updates follow the regularized leader
and this is just the odd algorithms we
have
and the learning rates the choice of
learning is the same as q learning we
have uh this is like one over one over t
roughly one over two h over one y over t
so the key steps is two things as i
emphasize one is incremental updates on
the v value instead of q value so this
is why we call it v learning instead of
q learning and the second thing is we
will run no required learning algorithm
for each states so those are the key
ideas of the learning algorithms
yes just to verify that e is one
globally not operational
[Music]
v is uh we have a v criteria so we're
going to update the per iteration so
this is a v added around t and is around
t plus y
when we were entire game yes
uh no actually uh sorry this is like a v
learning is a single asian
learner learning algorithm so we will
have this v is only for for the agent
itself so different agent will have
different
via like a v-value
so here this is all where i talk about
single-engine algorithms
so okay i will just briefly talk about
guarantees so i introduced the vlearning
as a single engine learning algorithm
for multi-unit setting we just run the
learning independently for all the
players
and we will use adversarial bandwidth
subroutine which is the following leader
we introduced earlier
so we can prove um in our early work
that is in two players zero sum games
the v learning with the follow regular
leader is able to find epsilon nash
equilibrium in this amount of episodes
so the important thing is now we no
longer
pay something in product of a1 a2 now we
only play the max a1 a2 or like a1 plus
a2
and in the later work we can also prove
in general sums games we can extend
these results to finding epsilon
course coordinate equilibrium in this
amount of episodes so so this amount of
resources is no longer product of ai but
it's max of ai
so i just want to finally emphasize that
we're learning as if i found that
earlier vlan is the first and also
remains the only up to today the class
of decentralized algorithm that able to
breaks the curse of multi-agents so if
you if we'll talk about a
multi-generation reinforcement algorithm
that is a part number in everything but
also number of agents
i think we're learning up to now is the
only algorithm that able to do
polynomial for everything yes
can you go back to the
interest
report
so now what you're doing is you're
running this banded algorithm right what
you're presenting it's abandoned so
um
you have to relate the best in hindsight
kind of changes because you're running
no regrets and the best in hindsight is
going to be with respect to this law
system to construct yeah that one is
only in another
algorithm you don't need to computer
what is the best thing
no i'm not saying you have to conclude
i'm saying like in the analysis you have
to relate that to
the to the
practitioner's laws
from the fictitious laws you have to
relate to the actual game right
uh it's easy to do because we only do it
state-wise we're not doing it like for
the entire market because it's only
statewide it's running out either
abandoned so we don't have anything
about the sequential thing so we can
just use the standard
follow-the-wireless leader analysis
or a sliding yeah one five version okay
sorry all right
maybe we must have a quick one because
we need could you explain why you're
using the functions out of the q
function like why couldn't you just
express that as a q function update and
could you also tell me you know this
episode what is episode defined as is
that like
when every time
when you'll finish a game of star
play a thousand steps and the game ends
that is one episode and we as i
emphasize that we use q value here
because q only depends on s well our v v
depends on s well q depends on s and a a
is like joint action so if you have
joint action you always play something
exponential
like a something product of a i well
here the b value is only depends on s so
kind of we get rid of the product of the
x we kind of break the cursor from the
moment it's just because you only input
in that second red step so you say
you're ignoring all of that expansion
okay
i'm not ignoring but we would not we
don't incur that kind of thing okay
probably we can talk about that the data
is a little bit
behind so this is the first and
remaining only algorithm that is a slow
both scenario and that's the total
phenomenon
now this is a very quick places uh we
also deal with according course
coordinating equilibrium the only thing
is uh
we continue with the coordinate
equilibrium without force the only thing
we need to change is instead of writing
another red algorithm we will write no
slow progress which is a stronger
definition instead of competing with the
best position inside will compete with
the best policy in a sense like
what if i gonna swap all the iterations
i play action a two to action b i can i
can basically swap all the actions to
different actions so in a standard
number algorithm we have to slope all
the x into a single fixed action now i
can switch to different actions so this
is different and harder and we're able
to show that we just changed this uh
like i have a serial bandage
some routine with the photo regulator
with swap with some swap
type of
modifications with a polaroid leader
we're able to find its own horsepower
equilibrium also in this max a i think
the only thing is like we pay this
square because we need to deal with
slope it's kind of a little bit harder
i just want to finally give some
bibliography notes about
yeah
we just made it
to the very end of the topic yeah yeah
so the very first work we proposed
learning is in back in 2020 and then
later after one year back through
current work realize we can extend this
results to like combining c and c for
multipliers or something so we have this
general verb general version which is uh
for vlearning and also their works by so
many by and also now and purposeful
the major difference i would say this
one didn't deal with ce and the other
thing is probably just the algorithm
slightly different and also the rate we
get is a little bit sharper in terms of
age dependence
similar to what
all of them use a very style algorithm
yes so that's why i claim this is like
so far the only style algorithm not able
to achieve this kind of thing okay i
just want to give a summarize of what we
presented so far today so in two-player
zero-sum games we can find this in terms
of nash in this thing and in cce ce we
can play for multiplayer general some
games
and the important thing is that we only
play a where a is max ia we no longer
play some product of
ai so we're not playing curse of
multi-agents and it's decentralized
algorithms
so the conclusion we have the first
algorithm that is decentralized and
breaker curse of multi-agents there are
several future directions i want to say
a little bit first thing is h dependence
so we have h to the fifth which is not
very sharp
and the techniques to shaping this h
dependence is a little bit different
from the standard reinforcement learning
which you can use
instance bernstein inequality and some
other various reduction techniques here
because we use no regret algorithm so we
need to use a sharper bounds on the no
regret algorithm which involves
different techniques
second thing is about output policy
although the algorithm is a little bit
is quite clean but the output policy i
haven't mentioned is a little bit nasty
we require some nasty mixture of output
policy we can prove that policy is not
equilibrium or cce
so we're able to have some clean output
algorithm for the two player zero sum
setting and for the multiplayer setting
i believe later by this clark's group
they have some mark of output policy but
they incur some
some quite a sub optimal dependency on
all the other states and number of
actions so how we get clean output
policy while have like a sharp
complexity is kind of still open
question and finally how to combine this
with a function approximation and how to
design this towards a practical
algorithm because in practice we should
hopefully we combine this learning with
the deep neural networks that kind of
thing is still quite open
okay and we also have some blog posts
about the multi-reinforcement learning
written with you by and i want to have
this is like the link
let's
finish my talk thank you very much for
attending
thanks a lot
for every agent they somehow need not to
recycle or kind of like converge to an
optimal
thing with respect to one another i
guess this was addressed
so how do you make sure that thing
happens they don't cycle somehow
i believe we don't actually show the
reader and come available converse to
um you know we shall actually put per
state
for per state we actually
well actually i think we we do show like
this uh this is like essentially gives
your upper bounds because we have this
uh cabinet set and this uh this
will eventually converge will be
starting some regrets
because we can just directly plug in the
guarantee of the for the regularized
leader we're able to say whatever they
are playing this round is gonna compete
with the
best policy in hindsight
and that plus policy inside eventually
we're going to relate that with the
best like the exploiting positive like
divided gap in the final regress
guarantee we have essentially which that
so that's kind of
it's kind of complicated yes you're
right and uh in a general time setting
you cannot show this is like connected
to a single because you have multiple
cce and c like they're not unique so you
might jump from one to the other but
eventually we can see asymptotically
it will converge through it's kind of
something similar to
to this uh
ballistics essentially if we general
sound mode by learning you can also show
this one
will come into the cc but it's just one
single cc it's
for that to happen
that you wrote on the on the b value of
the day
with next slide this line number
whatever the blue line there
uh that that's also true the reason is
like we can pick the learning rating
will be this this is the actual vertices
of
one one over t if this one over t is
just average then this is not available
so h over t will have anything where the
later updates so it's time tomorrow has
a magnetism to forget what is happening
in the past so that's why it has some
no rap components
maybe a related question is kind of what
is the notion of like optimism that this
choice of uh v that you're doing
satisfies
uh
we can't prove this uh you mean like
what is the upper bounds on this thing
yeah so i mean like i actually so why
are you adding beta t right like you're
adding a t to try to make this thing
optimistic right so the players are
actually exploring right yeah so i guess
i'm just asking if we look at like vh at
a given time
why why we're adding this bonus no no i
was just going to say like so what is vh
optimistic with respect to in a
two-player zero-sum game is much clearer
it's like uh it's just a optimistic
respect for the nash value yeah okay
cool and uh cce is
more complicated as i said because you
have multiple cc i would say it's like a
optimistic in the final it is finalizing
company version against
uh the cceu conversion tool that is
so can you extend this or have you
thought about extending this to the
discounting case and is something
related to what you were just saying
about this learning rate making that
difficult
uh
okay the this kind of setting there is a
trivial way to do this coming setting is
uh basically say i'm going to truncate
the
this condensate into some one over like
if i did this kind of parameters gamma
and i can truncate the steps to one over
minus gamma so basically up to that
steps all the future was like too small
i don't care and i can just directly
apply those results to to deal with this
like
this like this common sense and if
you're asking something that is like
more restricted like in the proper
learning sense like i want to have a
policy that is independent of price
independent steps i won't have like a
stationary policy
i think that one
we can prove i think the
that's blocked because their group has a
recent paper which shows you cannot
through that integrity
this is like
even computing the station like the
stationary mark of ccd is people
so that is if you want to do improper
learning everything is easy you just
apply this if you want to do proper
learning then
are there any other questions
maybe in practice even just for a single
agent case how does it could then
perform learning for instance
experimentally
we haven't run the experiment yet um but
i would imagine it's so
probably similar
all right let me go ahead and stop there
we'll have a quick break until uh 11 30
and then we'll come back for shops talk
but yeah let's uh let's thank chi again
that's a great talk thank you